It would take them one and one fifth of an hour or six fifth hours to complete
that work together. And converting that to minutes, it would take them 72
minutes total time to complete the work or one hour and 12 minutes. Great work
if you found these two numbers. We want to take our equation and solve for x.
We know that this fraction represents the amount of work that they both can
complete in one hours time. So x represents the amount of time it takes for
them to do all of that work, or to complete the entire job. So we can solve
this equation by multiplying through by the LCD, which is 6x. We simply
multiply these denominators together, since the greatest common factor among
them is one. We simplify this to 3x, this to 2x, and this fraction to the 6. We
add like terms on the left to get 5x equals 6, and finally we divide both sides
by 5 to get x equals 6 5th hours. We know 6 5th's hours is the same thing as 1
hour and 1 5th of an hour. And digging all the way back to fractions in our
clock, we know 1 fifth of an hour is really 12 minutes. Now, if you didn't know
this off the top of your head, you could have simply divided 60 minutes, which
is 1 hour, by 5 to get 12 minutes. We know an hour is 60 minutes. So, all
together, this would make 72 minutes of time. So this is how we know that the 2
of you can solve all of the problems in 72 minutes or 6 5ths hours.